الينا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي سيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي بعد 100
يوم من الحرب الاسرائيليه المتواصله على
قطاع غزه ما هو تقييمكم لحصي ما حققه
الجيش
الاسرائيلي نعم تحيه لكم لمشاهدي قناه
الجزيره اهلا بك نعم لا شك بان هذه 100
يوم حقيقه كانت حافله بالكثير من الاحداث
اذا ما اردنا ان نتكلم عن بدايه هذه
المعركه فنتكلم عن قصف تدميري قاده جيش
الاحتلال من القوه الجويه ومن القصف
المدفعي وجميع الاسلحه التي يمكن ان
تستخدم في مساله التدمير لقطاع غزه بعد
ذلك بدا الهجوم البري وهذا الهجوم البري
بدا على جبهه ضيقه باتجاه القاطع الشمالي
من قطاع غزه على اعتبار بانه بان
المعلومات كانت تشير الى ان مركز القياده
كان يتواجد في الشمال وبالتالي بدات
العمليه الع عسكريه على القطاع الشمالي
واستخدم الجيش في هذه المعركه الفرقه 36
الفرقه المدرعه 36 والفرقه 162 والفرقه 98
والفرقه 99 والفرقه 252 جميع هذه القطعات
العسكريه بالاضافه الى قطعات اخرى جاءت من
القيادات الوسطى ومن القياده الشماليه
لدعم القياده الجنوبيه في هذه المعركه
وبالتالي وضع الكثير من الاهداف لكي
يحققها هذا الجيش في هذه المعركه ومن هذه
الاهداف تدمير القدرات العسكريه لحماس او
نزع سلاح حماس في هذه المنطقه ه تحق له اي
من الاهداف التي تحدث
عنها نعم نعم دعيني بس اذكر بعض الاهداف
اللي وضعها الهدف الثاني هو قتل القاده
والهدف الثالث اللي هو مساله اطلاق سراح
الاسرى الذين متواجدين لدى حماس ولكن جميع
هذه الاهداف اذا ما جئنا اليها بعد 100
يوم نجد بان جميع هذه الاهداف داف لم
تتحقق ولكن اذا ما جينا على المستوى
العسكري على المستوى التكتيكي نرى بان
هناك توغل في المنطقه الشماليه لهذه
القطعات هناك دخول للكثير من المناطق ولكن
لم تكن هناك سيطره ميدانيه مطلقه لهذه
القطعات في هذه المناطق وبعد ذلك عندما
بدات المرحله الثانيه والثالثه بدا
الانسحاب من القطاع الشمالي تاركا بعض
القطعات لغرض التطهير والمراقبه والان نرى
بان العمليات بدات تعود الى القطاع
الشمالي بشكل كبير جدا بعد ذلك حاول ان
يوسع العمليه العسكريه بانتقاله الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه باتجاه خان يونس والى
القطاع الاوسط وهو الان يخوض معارك ضاريه
في هذين في هذين المنطقتين وبالتالي هو
يحاول الدخول الى جميع مناطق غزال لغرض
انه يقول باني استطعت ان احقق هذه الاهداف
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه سيطر على 60%
من قطاع غزه ما مدى دقه هذه التصريحات او
المعلومات
نعم لا شك بانه هو يقول بان الافضل بان
تكون التسميه بان اسطعت ان ادخل الى كثير
من المناطق قد تصل النسبه الى 60% ولكن
اذا ما جينا الى السيطره الميدانيه لا
توجد هناك سيطره ميدانيه مطلقه والدليل
على هذا بان اطلاق الصواريخ الصواريخ
بالامس كان من القطاع الشمالي وهذا يعني
بانه لا توجد هناك سيطره مطلقه لقوات
الاحتلال والدليل على هذا بان القاطع
الاوسط الان معارك ضاريه في هذه المناطق
في المغازي في دير البلح في في النصيرات
في في كثير من المناطق في في جنوب خان
يونس المحور الشمالي المحور الشرقي المحور
الجنوبي جميع هذه المحاور هي مشتعله
ومعارك ضاريه وهناك خسائر لقوات الاحتلال
تتكبدها في هذه المناطق اذا لا يمكن لنا
ان نتكلم عن 60% يعني حتى عندما نتكلم عن
القطاع الشمالي القطاع الشمالي الان هو
بدا انسحب الانسحاب من كثير من المناطق
وبدات فصائل المقاومه تقوم بعمليات على
القطعات المتبقيه هناك وهذا يعني بانه لا
توجد سيطره ميدانيه لقوات الاحتلال على
هذه المناطق طيب تقييمكم لاداء المقاومه
منذ اليوم الاول حتى الان من حيث التكتيك
والوسائل التي تستخدمها
والانضباط نعم فصال المقاومه حقيقه تقود
معركه دفاعيه ناجحه لحد هذه اللحظه ف طوال
هذه الفتره يعني عندما نتكلم عن هذا عن
موازين القوه نجد بان هناك اختلال كبير
جدا في موازين القوه ولكن مع هذا استطاعت
فصائل المقاومه ان توظف الكثير من نقاط
القوه اولا استطاعت توظيف الارض بشكل كبير
جدا وهي تستخدم الانفاق الان بصوره جيده
في تنفيذ العمليات باتجاه القوات المتقدمه
سواء كانت في خان يونس او في القطاع
الاوسط بالاضافه الى القطاعات الشماليه
التي تكبدت فيها قوات الاحتلال خسائر
كبيره اجبرت على على انها تسحب بعض
القطاعات التي تعتبر هي من قطاعات النخبه
وتسحبها الى خارج المعركه لغرض اعاده
التنظيم نتيجه الخسائر الامر الثاني بانها
تعمل ضمن منظومه متكامله وهذه المنظومه
تمثل قدرات عسكريه نستطيع ان نقول قدرات
عسكريه متكامله في كل منطقه بحيث تستطيع
ان تدير عملياتها العسكريه بمعزل عن
المناطق الاخرى وراينا هذا واضحا في
الشمال والان نراه في الوسط وفي الجنوب
المعارك تستعر على جميع محاور التقدم يضاف
الى هذا بانها استندت على معلومات دقيقه
يعني المدافع ليس من واجبه في مثل هذه
المعارك وفي هذا الاختلال الكبير لموازين
القوه ان يحتف ان يحتفظ بالارض ولكن من
واجبه ان يقوم بالانسحاب من مناطق قد تؤدي
الى خسائر ثم يظهر في مناطق غير متوقعه
لايقاع اكبر ما يمكن من الخسائر في القوات
المتقدمه وهذا ما حصل في جميع المعارك
التي جرت في الفتره الماضيه لذلك نرى بان
التكتيكات التي استخدمها حسب طبيعه
المعركه وحسب الموقف التعبوي وحسب القوات
المتقدمه للجيش الصهيوني لذلك نرى بان
هناك استخدام جيد للاسلحه المضاده للدروع
وهناك خسائر كبيره جدا وصلت الى لحد الان
اكثر من 900 اليه سواء دبابات او سواء
اليات مدرعه هناك استخدام لاسلحه التي بي
جي التي تستخدم لمعالجه الاشخاص هناك
استخدام للقنص بندقيه القنص بشكل جيد جدا
يعني نستطيع ان نقول التقيييم هناك
استخدام
ايضا الهوان حسب حسب بداياتها هناك
استخدام للاسلحه في محيط غزه لضرب
التجمعات وضرب الدعم اللوجستي للعدو هناك
استخدام لهذه الاسلحه لضرب مراكز الثقل
السياسي في تل ابيب وبقيه المدن الاخرى
شكرا لك العقيد الركن حاتم كريم فلاحي
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
اسطنبول